I don't go deep on fighting I go deep on
like after I watched Irish man went deep
in a Jimmy Hoffa oh yeah yeah you don't
learn about him in school no I knew he
went missing and was like he's a union
leader and you like you know you like
how he disappeared insane it's also
crazy how many people took credit for
killing him a ton it was kind of like
the do they think pain this was well
this is based off a book called I heard
you painting houses where it's from this
guy the Irish man where a lot of people
think he's full of [ __ ] yeah and
actually there was a guy whose balls
deep in Jimmy house kind of a ruin for
me because I read that people thought he
was full of [ __ ] so I had trouble with
it yes end no but even the FBI is like
well he's 8 on our list and as far as
suspects so they were suspecting him but
when you look at there was a guy who
used balls even Jimmy Hoffa came out
with his like book his official book
yeah went up to Robert De Niro during
the press and was like dude you [ __ ]
us this guy's full of [ __ ] this isn't
the narrative and you're glorifying this
guy's [ __ ] book and heat but the
same thing this Irish guy who said he
did it Frank yeah he also said he sold
the guns dude that killed JFK
he said he's done a bunch of stuff so
there's another book there great book
about richard kuklinski the Iceman yeah
and he did like he did the bull Gravano
so he's not even a [ __ ] did anymore
for the Mafia a lot of these guys do
kuklinski they all say oh sure we'll
clean Johnny a light and and and [ __ ]
a bunch of hitmen were like this guy's a
[ __ ] this guy richard kuklinski the
Iceman is a book by a guy named Philip
Carlo that wrote this book and kuklinski
was this polish guy from Jersey City and
he did he worked for all seven families
interval yet including New Jersey
taraf watch his brother get beat to
death in front of him read that book
it's so [ __ ] crazy they made a really
shitty movie about him with Michael
Shannon dead I was bummed out I was so
high standing there making it tears I
love Michael Shannon but if you watch
the old HBO interviews so creepy so
Iceman nice so they called me nice way
because you didn't give a [ __ ] but why
why do they all say he was a piece of
[ __ ] and wasn't even in the Mafia no
hold on keep going man I spent chin he
was uh
no he [ __ ] legit he didn't hurt but
everyone the Gambino's let Johnny a lie
but what did he say about Hoffa he said
he killed Hoffa in the book in the
you he's like they I went to Chicago I
was in Chicago he tells how he did it he
said he stabbed him in the back of the
head kept the knife in then they drove
it to a [ __ ] compound law got rid of
the car in in the book The Iceman by
Phillip Carlo and where does he say the
bodies that said he says he doesn't know
what in the steel what he does near him
though did the character class Irish man
was friends with him but the Irishman
was also in Detroit at the time with him
all the time right
he kind of yes it's confident for sure
but the other thing is you know when
they say he was buried under the giant
Stadium oh yeah the Yankee Stadium yeah
you so you know what they looked into
that there's so many the Mafia who did
all the construction that for all the
stadiums based in the East Coast
yeah they uprooted and went through it
they found so many bodies buried under
is not reporting it that's so funny is
there like in my field there's why many
bodies New York in the 70s and 80s
they're like good night you want to put
them in the boys are guyline so the
skyline on 20 and 22nd meatpacking the
word word it's like a beautiful place
now you walk up there it was a old
railroad thing yeah
dude so how many bodies up there it
wasn't just homeless people it was like
you know the mob would just cuz again
what brought the mob to its knees video
cameras just catching them well but
there you can't kill people anymore
they can trace you with video cameras
the cops is called dude they do it they
just draw a line up now they've changed
the inside Afghan and heroin yeah they
just kill guys you know bodies were
dropping off in the resuit I bet if you
went through the East River um it just
[ __ ] told it all the skulls you would
pull dude and the guns oh dude it's
crazy but that's what that's the thing
about like growing up in Colorado
there's like a history of Colorado
that's maybe a hundred and fifteen years
old maybe before it was Apache and
Arapaho oh no all the tribes that
lieutenant Barnes
yeah Western Sioux you know just really
respecting the land being decent and
then white man coming through putting
down tracks but you go to New York
there's these buildings that are like
400 years old yeah 500 years old you're
like oh I bet there are body not a
percent body you know with Jimmy Hoffa
but how they can't find the body is it
buried in Yankee Stadium John same maybe
but you know they owned all the
so if they did just you know set the
body on fire that makes most sense we're
fine well also you know what they do
some I guess the God is used to do or
can be knows just do is they would take
your body you kill you bleed you yeah
and then they cut you up oh that's like
Roy DeMeo and the murder assure you I
vote they throw you off the boat and
you'd be fish food yeah well they do
that up in little pieces there's this
place called Gemini lounge they used to
be in Brooklyn in Roy DeMeo and the MER
it was called the murder machine these
like these assassins for the Gambino
family and the Gottis they would just
kill people and they had a like a
restaurant in the front and then in the
back was like kind of an apartment and
there was a bathtub Kuklinski talks
about him in his book yeah and he said
these guys would just drip dry them like
here and cut them open and let them
bleed out and then they'd just take them
out cut their hands there well they also
you said they also used to put you and I
the other thing it does it put you in a
car masher so they put you in the car I
thought he says he did with Hoff yeah
yeah and you'd be under 50 tons of steel
never but he said he stabbed Hoffa in
the back of the head then put him in one
of those things and now he's just a cube
of [ __ ] matter I did read that yeah
yeah but kuklinski you want to hear that
book is a fun read is it super dark
super dark but you used to take I can
read gangsters killing gangsters I can't
really like I was reading this serous
killer book by a hunter it was so dark
because there's kids involved and have
kids I can't do it yeah gangster I'm
gangster I'm all about it read that it's
a good one there are a couple moments
where like he when he was a teenager and
he learned he just didn't care about
taking life and he talks about this in
the book animals first when he was a kid
then in the [ __ ] 50s and 60s he would
go along the West Side Highway and he
would bump into homeless people and
whatever ones gave him attitude he would
hunt and kill that's how he practiced
but he had a family right well his fence
right loved his family his daughters
loved his daughters but then would beat
the [ __ ] out of his wife bad person yeah
he's a bad bad person but man what an
interesting [ __ ] my dad used to beat
the [ __ ] what does what did that beat
his brother to death in front of him
when he was five that's why he said he
had no what a failure there was seven
and who was five and wash his dad I'm
not sure that was in jail with him yeah
he had a younger brother too that was
like yeah Jesus Christ
well change boy they drop the ball
movie though really dropped it is so
good
Michael Shannon's the [ __ ] course easy
pick this roll up dude picked the script
up bro let me do it he worked for all
seven families too cuz he was polish so
they're like oh you can never be too
Hitler promoter so he's kind of 3/8 guy
yeah you just show up and kill they said
the first hit he did they went to the
West Village in this one of the mobsters
gave him a gun was like see that guy
walking down the street with his dog
kill him kolinsky just got out popped
him in the head got back in the guy was
like well you made ice and that's where
like they started calling me ice miss
crying he's shot him got back it was
like there we go
is that what you wanted the guys liked
created what the [ __ ] what the his
father destroyed him oh yeah his father
just cut the obviously turned the light
out inside that kid's head yeah he was
kind of like watch me make a much me
make a machine little piece of [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]